hello everybody and welcome back to the
channel so in our last video we talked
about an introduction to search indexes
and like the idiot I am I decided to
split this kind of category into two
parts both search indexes and
elasticsearch the issue though is that
there wasn't that much content for
either of them so what I'm going to do
is give you guys the Jordan boyfriend
experience and try and take something
that normally takes about 30 seconds to
two minutes and make it last around five
minutes anyways let's go ahead and get
into elasticsearch I am going to stall
as long as I possibly can let's get
started alright so like I mentioned
today we would be talking about
elasticsearch so what actually is
elasticsearch as I have three percent on
my iPad and try and uh run this one out
before it dies elasticsearch is
effectively a convenience wrapper around
Lucian now we spoke about Lucy in our
last video leucine is literally just a
search index and what that means is it
allows you to do all sorts of complex
search functionality
and that includes things like prefix
text searching suffix text searching
geolocation searching number searching
date searching all of that and so as a
result leucine in itself is really great
but it is not really meant to be a fully
managed service there's a lot that you
would have to do on your own in order to
make sure that it's running across a
bunch of nodes in a cluster so
elasticsearch instead it takes care of a
lot of that inconvenience for you and it
makes it all really easily managed how
do they do so well they give you a rest
API so you can go ahead and easily
basically add documents to the
elasticsearch query documents from the
elasticsearch it actually has its own
query language it deals with replication
and partitioning for you I think there's
probably a zookeeper or something
similar at the center of it somewhere
and also it's got some you know kind of
additional services that are nice such
as visualization logging monitoring all
that crap anyways how does elasticsearch
actually work in a way that uh you know
we can talk about how we best want to be
using it well elasticsearch is actually
going to be maintaining a local index so
if you remember from forever ago when we
started talking about partitioning we
discussed what a local versus a global
index was now a global index basically
means that for a given key on one of our
partitions we have all of the possible
values for it so that would be like over
here on the right as you hear there are
sirens in Chicago this is an unfortunate
reality of living in the city
I'm going to give that about another two
seconds before I get pissed off that
they're stopping at a light okay they
fully got caught in traffic and that
took like 30 more seconds than it needed
to anyways like I was starting to talk
about one thing that you could do with
elasticsearch is a global Index right
where unlike the left side over here
where you can see that on two partitions
we've got the key cherry we would have
cherry and all of its values on one
partition however when it comes to
elasticsearch that's actually pretty
tough because keep in mind that normally
in actual elasticsearch these document
IDs right here that might correspond to
documents might not just be IDs but the
full document so let's imagine each of
those is like a megabyte or something
because this is an inverted index and
each document ID could appear many many
times in the inverted index having a
global index means that you might
actually have to send that document to
many many different partitions and then
that effectively is going to eat up a
ton of space and it pretty much destroys
the point of partitioning in the first
place instead what we could do on our
local partitions is just make like a
reference to the document so you know
you store the document somewhere in
memory and then this is just like a you
know a low storage pointer so it's
obviously going to be a lot more
efficient however using local
partitioning comes at a pretty major
cost which is that if I now want to get
all of the documents that have cherry
and I'm over here on the left
I have to query multiple partitions and
then aggregate them over here on some
aggregator node
and that of course is going to increase
latency by quite a bit and so in reality
when we're using elasticsearch if
possible it isn't always we would like
to keep all of our searches limited to
just one partition at a time so what's
an example of this let's imagine I ran a
chat app like Facebook messenger and we
want to be able to search through one
chat at a time well obviously if every
single message is a document we want to
keep all of our documents in the same
chat on the same note because the whole
point is that we are going to be
partitioning those by chat ID because we
can only search the messages of one chat
at a time now of course if you're
someone like Amazon and you just have a
search bar and you know you're able to
search any single product on the site
with that search bar then you're kind of
screwed out of luck it would be nice if
you could partition products somehow
according to like the type of thing they
are for example Like Home and Garden or
cooking or anything like that and then
maybe you would have to select a drop
down before you searched but sometimes
the reality of the situation is is you
just can't partition that easily and
then you would have to aggregate all of
those search results
okay the last thing that makes
elasticsearch kind of unique and makes
it perform very well is its caching
mechanisms so in most part you know when
we talk about caching generally speaking
we're either going to take a piece of
our index and cache basically that whole
thing in memory or we would take an
entire query result that someone ran and
we would cache that because if it were
popular if a bunch of people were
running that particular query result
let's say everyone was you know
searching for the same post on Twitter
at the same time or the same group of
posts then it would be a popular query
result and we would want the whole thing
at the same time though sometimes you
can actually be a little bit smarter
than that and that's what elasticsearch
tries to do so it will actually cache
part of a query If part of a query is
very common or very popular so let's
imagine I go on Amazon as I do
and I go ahead and search for tissues as
I do no reason in particular and also
for you know tissues that are on sale
because I'm cheap that's just how Jews
are or maybe me in particular the point
is not everyone is such a degenerate as
myself to be searching for tissues but
most people are pretty cheap and they
are going to be looking for items that
are on sale so if we cash this part
right here of all the items that are on
sale and that was say on multiple
different nodes especially so it was a
slow query being able to Cache that
result would help speed up queries by a
bit and when everyone else is searching
for on sale items even if it's only just
part of their query being able to Cache
that result will help a lot anyways guys
like I mentioned I know this was going
to be a short video tried to drag it out
a little bit and just you know have some
substance to it but I hope it helps and
I will see you all in the next one